I want to talk about something
completely uncomplicated and super
simple the State of Israel I love Israel
and not just because it's technically my
neighbor No but also because it's the
latest site of a Trump promise made and
kept I made a promise
months ago Trump announced that he would
be moving the US Embassy to Jerusalem a
decision so bold
it was condemned by many policy experts
saying it could provoke violet chaos or
cause Armageddon but for a significant
number of American evangelicals that's
not a bug that's a feature the sooner
Armageddon comes the sooner evangelicals
get to fly up to heaven that's why they
know to treat the planet late a gas
station bathroom so so Trump made the
promise and you best believe the fox
news 18 went to Israel to watch him keep
it Donald Trump recognizes Jerusalem as
the capital of Israel he like King Cyrus
before him fulfilled the Biblical
prophecy of the gods worshipped by Jews
Christians and yes Muslims Amen Junaid
yes Trump is just like King Cyrus before
him it's well known that King Cyrus
hated the Babylonian press and refused
to apologise to John McCain's keep going
Janine Jerusalem is the eternal capital
of the Jewish state and that the Jewish
people finally deserve a righteous free
and sovereign Israel
and that's my open tell me what you
think on my Facebook Twitter and
Instagram oh I haven't seen a smoother
transition since Jesus ended his Sermon
on the Mount with blessed are the
peacemakers all right click to subscribe
and hit me up on snapchat now if you've
been watching the news you may have
noticed that there's been a little bit
of push back by which I mean deadly
clashes between Palestinians and the
Israeli army but if you've got a problem
with moving the capital to Jerusalem
take it up with Lindsey Graham we're
rejecting the Obama model of tepid
support this means you got Israel's back
you've you got a problem with Jerusalem
being the capital of Israel take it up
with God oh yeah great answer that's
what I use all the time don't like my
policies in the Middle East take it up
with guy don't want me to use your pool
while you're on vacation
sorry Brent take it up with guy curious
as to why I've been emotionally distant
for the last eight months take it up
with guy the point is this embassy move
is a good thing Trump celebrated this
accomplishment by sending his chosen
people to Israel evangelical pastors
from Texas Robert Jeffress and John
Hagee spoke at the ceremony today and
boy were they the right choice just
listen to Jeff versus bona fides with
Pastor offering a prayer at the Embassy
transfer ceremony Robert Jeffress
prompting Mitt Romney obviously a
prominent Mormon to tweet yesterday
Robert Jeffery says you can't be saved
by being a Jew and Mormonism is heresy
from the pit of hell he said the same
about Islam oh nothing says peace in the
Middle East like declaring Jewish people
and Palestinians equal
leave deserving of hellfire yep
as for John Haji Trump's other pastor
from Texas and grimace for Jesus he said
in 2008 that Hitler had been fulfilling
God's will by hastening the desire of
Jews to return to Israel a claim which
makes so much sense I see absolutely no
reason to explore it further so Thank
You mr. president
and congrats of the new embassy
Jerusalem Armageddon is probably right
around the corner but if you have a
problem with that take it up with God
[Music]